you can rebuild your entire
infrastructure on Kung Fu Panda 3 just
don't have sex with dead people so this
weekend because obviously Dancing with
the Dead may be the root cause of the
bubonic plague comeback in Madagascar so
the local name for this practice is from
adi hana also known as the turning of
the bones or body turning involves
families exhuming the bones of their
deceased relatives rewrapping them in
fresh cloth and dancing with the wrapped
corpses before returning the remains to
their graves as a result bubonic plague
is back thank you master
as silly as this all seems we obviously
want to be culturally sensitive here at
Lagos Carter and and emili´s and these
people do need help we do want to hope
the people Madagascar that's why this
Christmas we're going to be partnering
with Operation Christmas shoe box for
for every five dollars raised
we will send shoeboxes to Madagascar
filled with anthrax cultures are not the
same by the way you donate $20 we'll
send in Coney of course DreamWorks has
already capitalized on this announcing
Madagascar four penguins with sis I
don't move it move it they know how to
keep a franchise alive it's the
babysitter for me yeah it's not a race
it's not a right it's not a race thing
no but when you sit in space and aliens
look at our planet and see what
continent comes darker than the rest at
the night time Madagascar what island
you know same it's 2017 there too you
should be leasing at some point say come
on man yeah I read the story anything
with the dead is is the least of what
they do
that's a mild description we read that
it was back about we were having this
conversation and now I'm like oh well
they freaking deserve this think about
for a second the bubonic plague predates
scurvy it's a disturbing solution by
what a few hundred years come on that
was solved with a lime yeah the bubonic
plague is solved by not having
intercourse with dead people don't dance
with your dead uncle and you collect
royalties from Dreamworks from life
you're good you can rebuild your entire
infrastructure on Kung Fu Panda 3 just
don't have sex with dead people don't do
it are you just being ethnocentric I'm
sure there's a rocket scientist there
getting busy with his ants bones I'm
sure they found someone you know he
could be he could invent the next great
lasting light bulb there's no biologist
that says hey guys this is I know we've
been doing this for a while but this
isn't a great idea anymore
I've looked into this microscope thing
and it doesn't work I mean you look here
you're talking about many centuries ago
we invented the light bulb several
hundred years later Madagascar the
market it's the same problem I just
checked on that in rocket science by the
way yeah he's been recruited North Korea
he is lucky island guys Lisa don't dance
with dead relatives there they just
launched a new rocket it's just a
Madagascar if you bought it crashed what
are you gonna jet back I can see Guam
extension that's just a privately owned
island hey did you like this video it
what you didn't oh you're a cat person
well that makes sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video you know what crazy cat you
can get back you couldn't you can
comment below to as to why you don't
like it